it's a perfect example of how in today's
world there are so many other options
for how to
convey and present ideas and collaborate
on them that are
extremely efficient for us and if
anything the running into limits of like
how much we can cognitively process
as human beings we we suffer from
information overload and we need better
tools to help streamline
what it is that we actually have to
consume and make decisions on
but in terms of what the technology can
do it's just it's amazing it's just
absolutely incredible
to start us off what got you interested
in productivity to begin with
uh you know i've been in productivity
for
maybe almost two decades now i
was a uh i was a cio
for facebook for almost seven years
and my job there was a productivity of
the workforce
prior to that i was a cio for another
company and my job there
was a productivity of the business when
i go back even to the beginning of my
career
a big part of what made me an effective
software engineer and engineering leader
is
i was very jealous of my own and my
team's productivity how much can we get
done in the amount of time that we have
and that led me to you know focus a lot
on automation and streamlining things
and
so it's really been a big part of of my
life even though uh
it's really been the last uh four years
that i have
you know really claimed ownership of
like this is the thing i'm focused on
right now
um so but yeah it's it's been a big part
of my life for a long time
what are the changes you've seen over 20
years
well we have a lot more technology now
than we
did before so when i i don't want to
date myself too much but you know coming
into the
workforce um you know when when
i did uh technology was relatively new
so you had a lot of office automation
that was basically looking at things
like okay we used to manage things on
paper
and here's how we're going to manage it
in the digital world
so whether you you know take the concept
of a document
uh or a file uh and you basically
represent that in a in a computer
uh you know fast forward another 20
years we've started to throw that stuff
out the window we don't think about
files as much as we think about just
links to things
even uh you know the technologies like
uh email what is email email is the
electronic memorandum
that is basically its history memoranda
are cool when you can only communicate
on paper
but when you're in the digital universe
they are completely
like way too much overhead and that's
why people have moved to
slack and facebook messenger and
whatsapp and text messaging and all
those other things they're
far more efficient ways to
to communicate and so
i think we're in this wave now where
we're starting to throw away
the history of the technologies that we
utilize
even things like slides like powerpoint
slides why are they even called slide
because they used to be cellophane
slides that you would put in a slide
projector
to present your ideas uh out there and
just imagine how much friction went
into producing those slides so you
didn't really care about how they were
authored or whether they were dynamic
but in today's universe
they're all digital right who wants a
static slide with just a couple bullets
you need animation
video and other stuff so we're starting
to throw away all that stuff
and evolve into a pure digital universe
where
we're not constrained by how things have
evolved in the past but we're really
you know thinking towards the future and
especially with mobile devices and
ubiquitous connectivity
that you know things can be uh you know
really dynamic and rich
to facilitate that productivity i've got
buddy
my industry is nightlife and one of my
friends ray chan the
owner and ceo of candypants he was
pitching for his first event in vegas
so he's going in and he's thinking all
of us are very competent at what we do
but we're just small-time
british events creators why should some
like
huge time club owner of like arya or
xs or wherever he was in vegas listen to
him
and they were brainstorming around how
can we
really sort of make an impact with this
so what they decided to do
was get a specialist 360
uh videography crew and film at all of
their other events in dubai in marbella
in the uk
elsewhere on the yacht at the abu dhabi
f1
everything and they rock up to this
meeting and it's in the you know
75th floor of some beautiful hotel in
vegas or whatever
the guys come in they say okay ray like
uh let's crack on man you want to show
us you shows your presentation
and he pulls out a bunch of oculus goes
and puts them on top of all of the guys
heads and then he starts talking through
as they experience they're looking
around they're in they're on the yacht
in abu dhabi
then they change and they're they're in
the middle of a pool party in marbella
then it changes again and they're in a
nightclub in the uk
and um yeah when he told me that story
is like holy [ __ ] this is really getting
stepped up a notch isn't it for
presentations yeah
i mean it's uh it's a perfect example of
how in today's world there are so many
other options for how to
convey and present ideas and collaborate
on them
that are extremely efficient for us and
if
anything the the running into limits of
like how much we can cognitively process
as as human beings we we suffer from
information overload and we need better
tools to help streamline uh you know
what it is that we actually have to
consume and make decisions on
um but uh you know in terms of
the what the technology can do it's just
it's
it's amazing it's just absolutely
incredible and that's a great story
that's a really fascinating point that
you just made there that we've gone from
information scarcity to information
surplus in
probably 30 years yeah like 30 years ago
i would have wanted to be able to access
the
entire history of the earth in a on a
device in my pocket
and then probably probably
about the time that instagram launched
no maybe a little bit later maybe like
2012.
2012 was like maybe the sweet spot or
2010
and then it's just been like wildly
overshot now and you're right a lot of
what people's time is spent doing
is not getting more information it's
actually filtering out information that
they don't need
and trying to permit themselves to focus
on the essential few rather than the
trivial many
my my the bane of my existence these
days and there's really been two systems
one the calendar which i'm sure we'll
get into but the second
is email i cannot stand that platform it
is incredibly inefficient
and it goes back to its roots right you
know with an email all you need is an
address in order to
to send a message to somebody and it
basically follows
a moniker that every message is going to
be read uh
and processed and filed and i get now
300 messages a day easy uh and which
means if i don't spend an hour managing
my email
then tomorrow i'm gonna have 600
messages a day
it is incredibly inefficient because
about 80 of these things are not things
that are that important to me
uh it's not always obvious which ones
are
the important ones and which ones aren't
so it's very hard to use
a traditional algorithm to just filter
them all out
but uh it's just the wrong you know
mechanism
you take facebook as an example not that
uh you know facebook is is perfect on
any front
but the news feed basically recognizes
that there's only so much time
that i have to process information in a
day with facebook
so it's going to rank the information
that um
i see to be the information that is most
relevant
to me and i'm not even going to be aware
of all of the news feed stories that
it chose not to share with me i'm only
going to get the ones that the the
algorithm chose to
to provide uh now in that case that
um you know has some obvious
consequences but generally speaking it's
been extremely successful for
uh for facebook imagine uh
you know if we're able to do that in uh
you know in in a business context or a
work context how much more
efficient we will be i think tools like
slack
somewhat get there i don't have a lot of
spam and slack for one because you can't
just use my slack address to communicate
with me you got to be in my slack
group uh you have to be in the channels
that i actually
monitor and so that means that there's
higher signal
for me you still have the problem that
there's slack overload but at least
slack has more of a recency bias where
uh that tool is basically designed for
synchronous communication if i miss a
message that's really important it's
probably going to come
back to me so i'll just get another ping
and i don't need to go back and view
every single slack message that i didn't
see in the three hours between
i was last in the tool uh so these this
gets to like what
how productivity software needs to be
built for the future it needs to be
really designed to
fit a more efficient use of
and sharing of information which
many tools i think really struggle with
are we going to see
email start to fade away i mean is there
even really a
a realistic alternative to the
behemoth that is email at the moment
i don't think it'll die but i think
email is going to be
it already is less relevant it's a lower
signal uh
mechanism you you see this uh you know
in the consumer space with things like
social media
that information is not conveyed via
email it's conveyed via
you know their their own proprietary
platforms and instagram and whatsapp and
tick tock and other things
these are not email based systems in the
professional environment you've got
slack
in teams and now zoom with zoom chat
which i think are getting uh
they're bypassing the communication flow
that is email
email does provide one thing that nobody
has solved yet which is
the global directory if i have your
email address i can send you a message
and you know most of these other systems
don't
operate that way paradoxically that's
why they are effective
because they don't allow someone who is
disconnected from me to communicate with
me but you still need that mechanism
you know because you want to be
contacted by the recruiter or you want
to be contacted by
um you know that business partner that
you're going to have
that is trying to get in contact with
you to
do something with your company and if
you don't have something like email to
facilitate that i think it's uh you know
that's that's still a detriment so
until that problem is solved i think
email will continue to
exist but it'll become less and less
relevant the more it's used i mean
that's the paradox with it is
you know as people start thinking this
is a great way to talk about our
products
they're destroying the platform that is
you know had been
a great way for people to communicate
with each other you're right the
ratio of noise to signal just continues
to get
worse and worse and worse and anyone
who's got a public
facing email knows as well that one it's
just
trash it's a cesspool in there like this
stuff
like i i get randomly signed up to
mailing lists
someone's obviously seen the the footer
note on a website that's 15 years old
still got like some
email you know i mean like it's it's a
nightmare um
so i mean my my daughter is um 16 years
old she's a high school senior
uh she has problems with email right so
uh
she she hates the the mechanism it's
very formal for her she doesn't really
understand how to
use it she grew up in text messaging
snapchat so email is like this weird
thing
but uh i mean she's had trouble just
filtering through the noise even on her
school email and there's no spam
there at least spam as we would call it
from advertisers
nobody's contacting her via her school
address to tell her to go buy you know
lululemons or whatever
but she still gets way too much email
from all of the distribution lists and
all the communications from the school
and so the important stuff gets lost the
signal
is lost in that and that's the problem
with email is it doesn't provide a good
ranking mechanism
yeah this is something that i wanted to
get on to later but i'm actually going
to talk about it now
which is the relationship between
your productivity system and everybody
else's productivity system
that there is a an upper bound or
there's a
boundary on the domain of productivity
that you can take your own system to
as long as you have to interact with
other people and
for instance uh you've used this example
before about um
a finance department asking uh
particular salespeople
to log all of their expenses which took
a hundred times
more effort for the sales people but
made it really slick for the finance
department
and as anyone who's decided to venture
down the productivity rabbit hole knows
your system can be as slick as you like
but
if you are a doctor working for the nhs
in the uk you're on windows 95 and fax
if you are part of any sort of big
well-established company that is going
to take time to update their systems
the likelihood is they're not going to
be able to have your
alfred auto snippet shortcut like
coded preconceived idea macro
system that you can just run they're not
and so yeah the the marrying between the
two and the
the turmoil of knowing that you've got
your [ __ ] sorted and that you now kind
of have to slow yourself down
to get to everyone else's place is
something i found really funny
this was um the number one issue for
woven
because the problem that we're looking
to solve with calendars
time is like the most valuable asset
that we have there's there's only 24
hours in a day and in the work
environment it's usually more like 10.
uh so it's a very precious resource and
the system that we use to manage time
is generally very disconnected from the
things that we're doing
you don't actually use the calendar
to like coordinate the agenda of a
meeting you'll have to use something
else
you don't use the calendar in many cases
to even schedule you
will schedule over email over text
messaging and then when you're done you
actually send the calendar invite from
from the calendaring system so we're
trying to fix that
or we are trying to fix that by
addressing how the calendar is built
because the calendar is just broken in
terms of how it's built and i can talk
about that later if you want
um but going back to your point
we can come up with the most brilliant
calendaring back end if it doesn't
interoperate with how other people work
it's either going to create a huge
burden for them or they're just not
going to
be able to interact with others so the
biggest technical challenge for woven
has been to build a system that is still
compatible
for the people that you're going to
collaborate with on your events
that aren't woven users it needs to
synchronize
with their existing systems and degrade
gracefully and in a way that will allow
them to
to still interact and collaborate with
you and
we put a lot of energy into that and
it's
you know worked i think pretty
effectively but it is the hardest part i
think for productivity software
some companies do what we've done where
they bootstrap on top of an existing
technology i mean even facebook in
the early days would use um email for
some notification uh updates
others like slack just go and they rip
the band-aid and they go straight into a
completely different
way of doing things and
they've been successful in that but it's
hard it's really really hard
this whole thing i think is one of the
tricks with productivity software is how
do you
interoperate so that your new system
that you're using to make yourself more
productive doesn't create an undue
burden on the people that you work with
at the end of the day if
it doesn't work for everybody for a
group of people then it doesn't really
even work for you
yeah i agree man let's go back to your
your time at facebook
you doubled the productivity of the
workforce at facebook
what's the metric for that and how did
that happen
uh we used revenue per employee uh and
which is not the best measure but it's
very easy
to benchmark to look at other companies
and so we also looked at a couple of
other measures we would look at profit
per employee
and then within each business function
you could provide more specific
productivity measures like
um you know how many uh candidates can a
sourcer produce or can a recruiter hire
uh in a in a given period of time but at
a gross level we use revenue per
employee that number where we talked
about doubling the
productivity of the company was very
much based on
doubling revenue per employee looked at
a different measure we actually did even
better
the key strategy on this
was one just a an incredible focus on it
like this was
all my organization thought about was
workforce productivity
even things as like trite as the uh
the gates that we would have uh the
turnstiles that people would have to
walk through to come into the building
we looked at
you know how much time it would take for
someone to badge in
and walk through and in some cases we
had to rebuild them
because uh it took you know an extra 75
milliseconds
uh for the the badge reader to read a
badge because of the distance between
the badge and the badge reader and so by
moving the badge reader from underneath
a plate of glass to on top of the plated
glass
we were able to get an improved
throughput for people through those
turnstiles
that's how much we cared about things
and so when you got into
things like you know how do employees
meet with each other we wanted a tool
that was super easy so they didn't have
to ask an admin
um how do people um uh you know get
accessories we invented these uh
vending machines that a lot of companies
now have where you could just
badge into a vending machine if you
needed keyboard mice
uh batteries screen wipes like anything
that was technical so you didn't have to
go to the help desk for that
put these machines anywhere that
employees were even if we didn't have it
people
and you know certainly things like
how do we make the business function
like sales or recruiting
more efficient through technologies you
know with facebook hires a lot of people
and that's a lot of interviews to find
the right candidates at one point it was
37 interviews to hire one software
engineer
and so if you're going to hire 10 000 of
them you can do the math in terms of how
many interviews that that would require
um so the uh
you know we would build automation to
take care of the mundane for people
let's make it so that it's really easy
to schedule
candidates let's make it really easy for
people to do their performance reviews
and
and to get feedback from other people
within the company
and those were the the mechanisms that
we employed in order to
achieve those outcomes and you know over
time
they really started to compound and
build on themselves because we built a
technical asset that we could then start
using and reusing uh to get more and
more
uh capability into these functions
one of the co-hosts of the show johnny
he uh he was a big four accountancy firm
a few years ago and he decided he'd gone
through this
long process deciding he was going to
leave and start his own business and
become an entrepreneur and it was his
dream and blah blah blah
and um he talks about the process that
he went through
to leave and it was he went to the
terminal
the console that he had on his computer
went to r for resign
press the resign button are you sure yes
are you absolutely sure yes and that was
it
that's so good
you also said about um people automating
stuff so i've got a story here
a programmer wrote scripts to secretly
automate his job
so from this comes out the back end of
github a guy called narcos
on github when he left his job his
former co-workers
started looking through and realized
that he'd automated all sorts of stuff
so this guy wrote one script that sends
a text message
late at work to his wife and
automatically picks reasons from a
preset list of them
if his login activity was was ever on
the computer servers after 9 pm
he wrote another script relating to a
customer that he didn't like it scans
his inbox for an email from the customer
and uses words like
help trouble and sorry and automatically
rolls the guy's database to the last
backup
then sends a reply no worries mate be
careful next time
with another script he automatically
fired off an email excuse
like not feeling well working from home
if he wasn't at work logged in on the
service by 8 45
he called it the hangover script and the
best one he wrote the script that waits
exactly 17 seconds
then hacks into the coffee machine
through the telephone terminal
and orders it to start brewing a latte
the script tells the machine to wait
another 24 seconds before pouring the
latte into a cup
the exact time it takes to walk from the
guy's desk to the co the coffee machine
and his co-workers didn't even know the
coffee machine on the network was
hackable
that's the sort of [ __ ] that you need
that's the company you want
that's a good engineer uh you know i
think that
the best engineers are the lazy ones
they don't like to do uh repetitive work
so they come up with mechanisms to avoid
it whether that's through architecture
or through automation like you just
described this is
one of the things that made me
successful when i was an intern at
cybase my very first job
was i thought the job was boring as hell
and so i just automated it and
i took what used to take other people
eight hours a day i could get my job
done in about two
so i had six hours to go screw around
and do other things and so they just
kept giving me more work that i would
just
keep automating and but you know
this is the trick i think with
productivity you sit and you find the
repetitive things that do not add value
to your life that you must do and you
automate them
that can be done through delegation to a
subordinate or an assistant that can be
done through
actually not doing them at all um i
guess which is
the most beautiful part of your life
when you realize the thing that you've
been
doing no one's actually probably going
to know it so it doesn't add so little
value that you basically don't need to
do or as you say
write a script so time management what
are the basic
principles before we get into tools what
are the basic principles
people should understand around time
management
so one of the unique things about time
is how
limited it is and i don't think people
fully appreciate this
and we use phrases like you know waste
time
or you know not having time the reality
is we do
have time we all have the same amount of
time
and because time is so finite you really
have to be
very diligent about how you choose to
spend it
and this is where calendar i think can
be extremely valuable for
uh for people because what a calendar
typically represents is how you want to
spend your time how you're
planning to spend your time and if you
sit down you think
about it like you know if you're you
know if you have presentations to write
or
code to put to to build or um you know
you need to
uh you know get through your email uh
if you don't allocate the time for that
and those activities if you don't you
know plan for it
then either it's not going to get done
or it's going to get the done
at the expense of something else that
you may have that's even more important
because you're not being
diligent about it so time management i
think starts with
respecting the fact that there's only so
much time in a day
then the next key thing is to be very
clear about
what it is that you want to accomplish
what are your goals
and you know one of the the greatest
gifts in my life was
being introduced to a life coach
earlier on in my career who helped me
like write this stuff down
like what were my big strategic goals in
life
when did i want to have kids and when
did i want what kind of house did i want
to live in and when did i want to retire
blah blah and basically you go from big
to small you start defining these things
and then you can map that down into what
do i need to do
um next next week next next month next
year
uh in fact i still have one of the
things that this guy
had me do hopefully you can see this is
fill out this card
um and it's basically this is your life
is what the title of the card is and it
starts with
like my birth year and then i had to
write out 100 numbers
until like the age of 100 and then i had
to circle
where i was in my life at that time uh
he also had me
circle when it is that i wanted to
retire and then it
helped me see like how little time i had
left and it created urgency
to make a make tough decisions
on things that i was i wanted to spend
time on
uh one of those things was i didn't want
to be in the semiconductor industry so i
ended up resigning my job i had a very
lofty executive position
but i chose to leave that role because i
didn't want
to you know retire from the
semiconductor industry i wanted to start
my own company
and i wasn't going to do that working at
this place
and but you know a number of other
decisions came out of that so once you
have like
those goals defined and then you narrow
that down to how do i want to spend my
time
you know over the next quarter you can
start building a normative schedule for
yourself
i for example i put you know mondays are
my favorite days of the week i'm fresh i
relax from the week weekend but it's
very important for me to
not immediately jump into collaborating
with other people but to have
some strategic planning time so the
first two hours of my
week are strategic planning time that i
save for myself and i almost
never give that time up for somebody
else
i organize my week so that all the
planning things are done monday and
tuesday so that means the rest of the
week is mostly about execution
my team has a commitment to each other
that we're not going to spend time
meeting
on wednesdays that allows us all focus
time
uh time to just get stuff done and
so on and so forth so i've got a
normative schedule that is pretty well
defined
and that helps me to like meet my
goals and time blocking and
pre-allocating that time on the calendar
is a very effective strategy to ensuring
that you get
done the things that are really
important to you time blocking being
just
deciding in advance what you're going to
spend
hour x to our y doing that's right
that's right
and it could be on a recurring basis as
i just described i want to spend the
first two hours a week like getting
ready for the week
or it could be uh on a you know an as
needed basis
i'm meeting with an investor on thursday
and i need to prepare the deck that i'm
going to share with them
so i'm going to put an hour of time on
wednesday to finalize that um
it you know whatever it is you get what
you
focus on it can be on on big things
on on recurring things or it can be um
on tactical objectives that that you
define but
the key point is you get what you
what you focus on and time blocking
allows you to be very deliberate about
how you are going to focus your time
yeah there's a few doorways to hell that
i've got open in my mind one of them
being parkinson's law work expands to
fill the time given for it
and i've been thinking recently about
what happens when you scale parkinson's
law
in an information surplus world out
across a lifetime
like essentially what parkinson's law
does is
probably push a lot of the important out
of the way
in place of the urgent uh and you will
just continue to kind of put out fires
and put out fires and put out fires
and never really get around to that and
that can be irritating
over the micro slash immediate
it can be kind of worrisome over the
medium term
but it's existential over the long term
right like
it wouldn't surprise me if we get to the
the stage where in 20 years 30 years
time people's biggest deathbed worries
or regrets uh stuff like i spent too
much time on email
i spent too much time on my phone you
know we haven't encountered that
there's a lot of good articles if you
google biggest
um regrets on on deathbed there's some
really
enlightening and sort of beautiful
insights
that nurses have got from that but we
haven't seen
what the outcome is of this information
overload world
and i'm i'd bet a significant amount of
money
that stuff like social media and youtube
and
email and digital work is
absolutely going to make its way up that
top chart higher up there
of regrets there's another framework to
think about time which is that you have
um i've heard some people use the the
words maker time
and managed manager time uh make your
time being the time
where you're like doing something your
your uh
your coding or your your your authoring
uh
manager time being um you're responding
to the needs of others you're
you're you're you know taking care of
the things that that require
collaboration
there's yet another way to look at that
which is your proactive time and your
reactive time
you can't have none of the reactive time
because the world is going to move on
without you
and as much as we may want to have
control over
100 of what we do things change and you
need to spend time
absorbing that and reacting to that so
you need to read the
email you need to go to the news feed
but it's got to be boxed uh if it's too
much of your time then that's where
those regrets are going to
to come about on the flip side of it is
maker time i would assert that most
people
don't aren't deliberate about their
maker time um they don't
think about where they are most
productive
and there is definitely um you know a
pareto here where
it's it's usually not even that much
time but twenty percent of our time
produces eighty percent of our value and
when you're able to be disciplined and
uh
and focused on that you can maybe
increase that a bit so it's not just 20
of your time and improve your overall
output and this is what i think people
like mark zuckerberg
have been very effective at
you know jeff bezos uh warren buffett
all of these people are
very very good at managing their time
they're not flippant about it uh then
yeah some others like elon musk who just
don't sleep so they've maximized their
time in
other ways but still same outcome
they're able to maximize their their
output from
these things and they're very jealous
about the time that they need to
think and um you know be proactive about
things and
uh the more that we can keep that
imbalance with the
uh reactive time i think than the more
effective we are as individuals
absolutely yeah the send versus receive
paradox that you've got going on there
is
is super important i can't remember the
i think it was
another jack butcherism from twitter
where he said
uh people spend their time like they can
refund it
and hoard their money like they could
never get more uh and we really do need
to kind of flip
that narrative on its head and yeah oh
absolutely
people being jealous to the point of
paranoia
about how they spend their time probably
brings us more in line with where we all
should be i guess um why do you see
most people going wrong they said they
think about i'm going to start
optimizing my time i'm really going to
that tim guy sounds all right he he had
some good stuff yeah i don't want to die
with regrets and unfulfilled dreams
what do some of the common errors people
make
i think for one not thinking far enough
out into
uh the future uh we can actually see
this with calendar data so
woven's got about 190 million events in
it and one of the
interesting things about that data set
is it highlights
most people don't fill their time
until they don't schedule events until
three days before the event occurs
uh or less so that basically
gives you a horizon for how far out in
the future somebody is thinking
and uh you know they uh
the it it basically highlights how
reactive that we are so i think that is
a a key
area where we we go wrong is that we
don't plan
far enough out in the future we have a
very uh strong
uh bias towards the here and now
and not towards uh the long term you see
this with things like
you know the best exercise advice isn't
that you know okay go
start working out at the gym for you
know 10 hours it's
you know work out at the gym every day
for at least 20 minutes if you did that
you're going to be far better off
in the long term because you're going to
start to institute the habit you're
going to start coming back to it over
and over you're going to allow your body
to adapt
and uh and evolve so we do too much of
this cramming and not enough about
thinking about the long-term
implications of the
decisions that we make and if we were to
plan more
our futures i think that we would be far
more
likely to accomplish but especially big
things
nothing worth doing is easy and
therefore you're gonna have to spend
time on it uh but not just today like
over time you really need to think about
what am i doing next week next month
next quarter one of the addictions
that i think a lot of people myself
included have
is this presumption
that time spent planning could be spent
working
so you have i'm gonna sit down i'm gonna
put my plans together
i'm gonna you know the next 90 day
sprint or the next year or whatever it
might be
um and you start doing a bit of planning
and an
easy to do task appears during the
planning process and you're like oh
i could send that email now and then
before you know it
you've cut the planning stage short and
tumbled
into the rabbit hole of doing and then
it's urgent and then information comes
in and then before you know it
the planning stage has been lost and i i
really do
i wish that i had a better process for
it but
i am absolutely a believer although i'm
not a member
of the fact that the cult that is
trying to make long-term you know what
is your obituary what your obituary want
your obituary to say
um what do you want to do in 25 years
when do you want to retire
where do you want to be in five years
time where do you want to be in one
year's time and then really
because that's the only way that you can
ensure that the actions that you take
today are contributing to the future you
want
tomorrow it's the only way that it works
but again the urgent takes over the
important and it stops us from
spending that time right like looking at
what are the steps i need to take and
you know it's a this is a plea from me
to anyone who's listening that
tends to be a doer rather than a a sit
back and planner
that you every minute of planning i
think is probably worth
ten minutes of doing and by spending a
concentrated period of time maybe two
hours at the beginning of the week like
you said or
you know once every month taking an
entire day off to check in with your
goals to do whatever
it feels like oh i'm gonna have 600
emails to answer tomorrow and i'm gonna
have
all of this other stuff to do but in
the big big big scheme of things it's
going to ensure that you continue
pointing toward that north star
but it's seductive because it feels good
to get something done
but there's a there's another hack on
this that will
that that uh i've found uh helps greatly
which is to spend
time not just planning but also
reflecting what did i get done
so in addition to my two hours a week um
at the beginning of the week planning
out what how i want the week to go
every day i've got what are the goals
that i have for today
uh and then at the end of the day i look
back what did i get done i write it down
into
my journal um and what is it that i want
to get done tomorrow
and it does a couple things it helps me
see
what i plan to do that i didn't get done
why maybe it wasn't important or
usually it's because i let the urgent
take over the important so how can i get
that thing done
um but also i get the satisfaction of
like looking at all the other all the
things that i got done
and it's usually more than i had planned
to do
and so the learning is how to make sure
that all the things that i plan to do
got done
um but also you know to give myself a
little bit of credit for the fact that i
get a lot done
like there's a lot of things that i'll
do in a day so when i just direct my
abilities towards the things that i
really care about
um you know i will get both the
satisfaction of getting things done
but it will be towards a master plan all
that stuff that i didn't plan to do
is firefighting or you know responding
to somebody else's needs
and you know usually not particularly
accretive to what my longer term goals
are sometimes it is but usually not
and uh so i found it to be a very
effective practice in in helping to
you know both alleviate the desire to
just check some boxes
and and say yeah i responded to those
emails or i you know got through my
email in a day and
stay focused on those bigger picture
items is that a
physical product is there a particular
system that you're following for that it
seems like an oddly low-tech solution
for you
yeah it's uh it's because this is less
about um the automation and more about
the emotion right so that what i have
found with this
is it doesn't necessarily feed
the systems that i have that will
automatically get stuff done what it
feeds is
my my feelings about myself and
and you know how i'm approaching my my
day so it doesn't really matter whether
it is uh in a note-taking app or
it's on a piece of paper i tend to be
you know purely digital so it's in a
note-taking app but even there i could
be
in you know apple notes today and notion
tomorrow and it really doesn't matter
because largely this is just a reminder
for me of what my
key priorities are i am thinking about
other ways to get this into woven
because the calendar is reflective of
this like what is it what's my goal for
the day
and how do we better incorporate that
and one of the things we have in woven
is
analytics that i do use on a weekly
basis to make sure that i'm spending
time on the priorities that i care about
in fact the mission of the company is
how people spend time on what matters
most
the analytics is part of how we help you
do that will give you visibility into
how you're spending time
scheduling is um you know a tool that we
provide to help you
spend time so are you spending time on
what matters most at the end of the day
i can see
you know through the analytics how how
that's going and i'll all have
objectives in terms of how much time i
want to spend with
um you know the product um
how much time i want to spend on growth
marketing how much time i want to spend
on recruiting how much time i want to
spend on investors
and they change you know based on where
we are as a
as a team but it's helpful for me to see
how how that time is being allocated
and when i'm doing that planning at the
beginning of the week it can lead to
adjustments you know i don't have enough
emphasis on recruiting this week i need
to you know work with my recruiter to
make sure that
uh either we're following up on
candidates that we have
that are ready to go or we're putting
more people in the pipeline so that
i'm spending time on recruiting because
that's a big part of our growth
one of the things i've been impressed
with a lot recently and i think
woven appears to be moving in a similar
sort of direction
is this post-information world
for a lot of personal productivity
systems so i'm thinking about
um the new era of wearables stuff like
whoop and aura
which actually don't they collect an
awful lot of data but what they feed out
is quite aggregated
it's kind of simplistic it's really the
minimum
viable the mvi the minimum viable
information
uh that you need to to get the work done
and
you know there's the quantified selfers
out there who would be
perfectly happy to have every
millisecond of data
that they can plug into their excel
spreadsheets with a vlookup and a
color-coded cells and stuff
but for the vast majority of people
we're in and it reminds me kind of
of the um the transition that we had
with products
from pre iphone to post iphone where
when you used to get a blackberry it
would come with like this
telephone book of a manual and the
unboxing wouldn't actually be that
and you'd have all this stuff and you'd
never really need it and you get it in
like chat all the instructions would be
chinese french german dutch like i don't
need all of that stuff and then
we get to okay what's the minimum viable
information that people
require like what is the most beautiful
and
smart user experience and it would
appear that the
transition that you're trying to get to
with calendar here you know it sounds
great
i love the idea of spending time at the
end of my week reviewing how i spent my
but it's like if it's not there in front
of me that's just another task on my
to-do list that i need to do
and as we've just identified we have
a bias toward doing things that are
immediately gratifying rather than
sitting planning and reviewing and
unless it's there
slap bang staring you in the face and
almost you need to like push
notification
out of the way it's like it's just not
going to get done does all of that kind
of map into
into your this is why we we have this
concept of home uh in woven and
so the the home section of the app both
shows you
the meeting that you need to go to next
um but it also shows you your analytics
for that particular week and the reason
we put it there is for exactly this
purpose that
if it's you know of course you're going
to be looking there to like
what is it that i have to do next so
you'll be reactive to that you've
already made those decisions we're going
to help you get into that event
um but the analytics are the piece that
you may not be thinking about
but when it's there it's a constant
reminder of you know what are your
priorities and
how are you performing against those
priorities
and uh so by integrating things together
into the calendar we've made it easy for
you the alternative
would be you know some people like
they'll pay their executive assistants
to go and you know
build a report or there are some
third-party apps that you can plug into
your calendar they'll give you
you know insights into your your day
they're not real time
um and it's effort and if you're gonna
have to spend that time
uh on it you're much less likely to do
it when it's right there in front of you
then you can immediately consume that
information in fact this is a whole
principle
in information management of cycle time
to information
one of the ways to increase value is to
give the information to people
um you know as as quickly as
it is collected as possible to reduce
the cycle time to uh
for for information and um so that's
something that we have
very much uh strive to provide on this
run but there's a lot more i mean
you also need trends you need to know
how is it you know it's one thing to
know i'm spending 25 hours a week in
video conferencing meetings
it's another thing to know that that has
been slowly ticking up
and that's the reason why i'm tired i
feel tired because
um you know maybe for me five hours a
day is about as much as i can take
before
i start to just get exhausted staring at
a computer screen all day long
and uh you know so when you have that
insight it can help
then lead to actions on how you might
want to remediate that issue or maybe
the
uh the trend has been to spend less and
less time on on marketing
and hey that that might be good for this
particular company because
marketing issue is under control or
maybe it's not maybe we're not
performing
from a marketing perspective and so if i
put more time into it i will i'll get
better output on
on that front in all cases the point
being that
information is both like when it's
easily collected and presented
that provides insight but when you can
also give you the context over time
it provides a different level of insight
and both of them are really valuable
yeah have you got plans to
expand out to task management as well do
you see the line between calendar
i.e sort of time management and task
management
being difficult so we spoke earlier on
about um
the interdependence of your system with
the people around you
but there's also interdependence within
your existing systems right
yep yeah uh basically events are tasks
you know we have a task right now let's
go record a podcast
that is an event we just both share it
a time block is a task so
there is a very tight connection between
those two things
uh and in many respects woven is
actually already well suited for it
because we have
the concept of an event that has yet to
be scheduled a
a draft event we call it and if we were
just call those draft events tasks we'd
have a task management system that's
actually really really powerful because
any task inside of woven could be done
with other people
and is collaborative and can easily then
turn into an event on the calendar and
it can even do it by itself through
the magic of scheduling links so that's
in our future there are some interesting
things to address
especially when you get into groups
because there's a lot of other places
where people put tasks they put tasks in
their note-taking apps they put tasks in
systems like asana or git
they put you know they they may have
full-on task management uh systems if
they're using a crm
so we have to think through how to
bridge
as we did with calendar events this new
universe where we're mapping those tasks
to time
and the existing universe of where
people
in different organizations might want to
be storing and managing their tasks
and that's i think probably the more
tricky part of task management but the
other parts in many respects we've
already solved we just don't
push that feature of the product just
yet yeah yeah i uh i had david allen
the author of getting things done and
grandfather i guess of the modern
productivity movement on a couple of
months ago
and i asked him i was like you know you
do you tell me do you use omnifocus or
do you use things three or have you got
like a
what's you and he was like i'm just
using this
old as hell like some python script
thing that looks like a casio a casio
calculator uh and that kind of really
reminded me
that the principles are served by the
tool
only for as long as the tool continues
to be optimal like if you people can
make a rod for their own back and
actually create
more work by getting a tool which is
poorly aligned and doesn't necessarily
do the job that it needs
yeah yeah yeah it is uh and this is
it's hard enough to build systems that
are simple i mean you talked earlier
about how
it used to be by a piece of technology
with a big thick book of
uh instructions on how to use it and
that's the world today will not accept a
solution like that you
you have to build your technology in a
way where it's easily discoverable but
simplicity is hard right it is difficult
to build
a powerful system that is simple
it takes a lot of engineering a lot of
thought um and so
uh you know this is one of our uh
current focuses
is to take the power of woven and really
try to
simplify how people can use and discover
it so they don't necessarily have it all
in their face
you know on their first day when they
come into the product
but it's still there it's still there to
you know provide value to them so we can
automatically format events or
automatically schedule events or
whatever it is that the
individual may uh may need uh and you
know those
those problems are valuable um problems
to address which is one of the reasons
why you don't want to expand your
feature set too wide too quickly so that
you can
make sure that you streamline things uh
that you have first
i was listening today to lex friedman on
the artificial intelligence part it's
not called that anymore it's just called
the lex friedman podcast but he's
talking about artificial intelligence
and he was talking about the fact that
the first company
to get an effective self-driving car
will get a lot of the benefits that uh
the first agi
super intelligence will because their
ability to compound on the data and the
analytics
is going to just exponentially skyrocket
their ability to
further improve their system and further
improve their system and further improve
their learning
and it really seems like you guys are
kind of mining that data to
look at you know what is it that people
want because a lot of the time we don't
even know what we want
you say to someone what's the what are
the sort of features that you would need
in your new mobile phone or in your new
whatever and someone would
rationalize what they think they want
and then you look at their usage and
you're like if i gave you that
you'd use it five times a year whereas
if i'd if i
managed to reduce this particular
operation down
by five seconds per time it would save
you 50 hours per year
or more you know so yeah it's um it's
fascinating man
i'm really interested to see how the
analytics driven world
is going to move into productivity i
think that's a really exciting area
well with time we will further stitch
together
um time events and what people are doing
this is
the long-term vision of the company uh
is
to make time an asset an information
asset and it will
be that when it's not isolated when it's
not all by itself so
when you know you're going into your
staff meeting and the agenda's already
there
and the follow-up action items are
connected to the event
and as we do that more and more then
those events can be smarter
you can start to see oh there's going to
need to be a follow-up meeting out of
this so let me help you schedule that or
maybe this uh you know event is going to
you know trigger the need to cancel
something that you have in the future
because you just made the decision on
something that
was already planned in the future the
more that we do that the more
intelligent we can make the calendar and
have it be a more proactive part of your
day in your life
where it's helping you to accomplish
your goals as opposed to just being this
administrative burden that you have to
pay somebody else to manage
yeah it really does feel we talked about
this kind of corner that we've turned
with technology
into the information surplus age it
really does feel at the moment like
that's what a lot of people want like
the number of
there's no one listening who thinks that
they have enough time in the day like
the the day that we're recording this
the clocks went back
last night uh sorry the night the night
before last night
and oh my god a day with 25
hours in it it was like it was so
beautiful how's that
i this is what this is what it should be
like but you know
i can't do that all the time sadly i get
that one second
in four months you're gonna have a date
no i know don't remind us about that
um do you know that there's a
statistically significant
increase and decrease of 25 in
heart attacks and strokes on both of
those days
and the same increase in decrease in
road traffic accidents
i'm not surprised that i've never heard
that statistic but i'm not surprised at
all
yeah from uh this was my my number one
challenge to my executive assistants at
both kla tencore and at facebook was
um they'd say how can we help you most i
think i need a 36-hour day and for
whatever reason they
all failed at it they could not i mean
it's a simple thing
just add 12 more hours of the day
somehow
the only time one of them figured it out
was uh
apparently if i fly from midway island
to
singapore um i can get
i can get that 12 hours but it only
happens once only happens once and then
you gotta lose it
i had a friend who set off on a flight
from hawaii to china um uh no sorry from
hawaii to australia
and lost christmas day set off on the
24th
arrived on the 26th and lost christmas
day and they had they had christmas on
the plane
apparently they had like the christmas
dinner but never actually experienced
what the 25th of december felt like
yeah yeah i mean every time i'd fly back
from asia
that was the one nice thing is that you
would get your time back
the travel date didn't exist on the way
back on the way there you're screwed
you're right yeah look tim thank you so
much for coming on woven.com
podcast slash wisdom if you want to go
and check out woven 21 day free trial
people can get the moment is that right
that's right hey your man knows it
that's what happens when joel sends out
the uh the script for the
for the pre-roll uh so yeah go and check
it out if this sounds like the sort of
tool that you guys
want to use i i am someone who
schedules an awful lot you know four or
five guests per week
plus all of the rest of the stuff i do
for running multiple businesses and and
everything else so
i'm looking forward to sinking my teeth
into the tool um
and i'm fascinated man you know it's a
really interesting time
the technology's finally sort of
permitting you guys to be able to do
the things that you need to do hopefully
to uh
counteract the amount of information
that we're all dealing with
well chris it's been a pleasure to be on
your podcast here and uh really look
forward to
seeing some of your viewers come and
check out woven
and we offer uh in addition to
uh the 21 trial 21 day trial we also do
some onboarding for our new users to
help them learn about the app and
very very committed to the mission of
the company to help people spend time on
what matters most
i love it tim thank you man
you